welcome to machine learning part two my
name is Richard Kirchner with the simply
learned team that's w w simply learn
comm get certified get ahead and today
we're gonna cover the random forest in
our if you remember from part one we did
the decision tree and no one wants a
poor lone standing tree out in the field
we want a forest and so we're gonna
cover random forest still play on words
there I'm sure the people who designed
it also knew that too when they were
thinking about it so what's in it for
you what is a random forest how does a
random forest work we're gonna cover
applications of a random forest some of
the terms you need to know when using a
random forest and then we'll go over the
use case and are predicting the quality
of wine so let start a little bit with
exploring what is a random forest and
welcome to Rafael's vineyard and I don't
even how to pronounce that in Alsace
France the largest wine production
region in the world so they have
centuries of wine production and data
they've collected on how to make the
best how to make their grapes and grow
them and how to properly get the red
grapes and ferment them like Raphael
winemakers around the world are facing a
grave problem so let's meet the man
himself and try helping him out what is
a random forest we're going to come back
to the vineyard but we're gonna get some
other examples along the way to open up
the door and of course here comes
Raphael at probably I probably look
closer to Raphael than I do to the young
lad with the beard Hey Raphael so tell
us how it's going not as good as before
not many people work in this profession
anymore so every stage of production has
gone slower if only we could somehow
speed up the process well lucky for you
I'm a machine learning engineer how
about we automate the quality prediction
process for wine let me begin by telling
you what machine learning and random
forest is machine learning is a science
of applying algorithms that allow a
computer to predict the outcome without
being explicitly programmed random
forest is an ensemble machine learning
algorithm so we're bringing in different
pieces and then putting those pieces
together it operates by building
multiple decision trees
remember I told you we don't want just a
loan
tree out there and we went to forest
they work for both classification if you
remember from part one we had our vendor
with his broccoli and oranges I think he
also had carrots and it also the output
given by the majority of its decision
trees is the forest final output so if
you have a number of decision trees you
have five decision trees and four of
them say it's broccoli then it's
probably broccoli you can also use it as
a regression model the output given by
the majority of decision trees is a
forest final output just I can do in
classification you can also come up with
actual values and numbers as a
regression model could you explain how a
random forest works in layman terms it's
always a good thing to explore the
information on something a little bit
easier to understand and see sure let's
consider the case of Sam a high school
student this so reminds me of my own
high school student who's just earned
his first year in college
asking all his friends so Sam is
confused on which course to take up so
he's trying to figure out what his next
class is gonna be at school should he
take music lessons dance lessons math
science maybe social studies so he
decides to ask a couple of his friends
for suggestions and Sam approaches Jane
first so he comes up to Jane and says
hey which of these classes should I take
and Jane asked Sam a few questions based
on which she can suggest theoretical do
you like theory no he doesn't like the
theory part calculative
do you like calculative yes I like doing
calculations and so Jane based on a
couple question goes she has a real a
decision tree there going she goes
mathematics sounds good so Jane's for
the decision tree based on Sam's
response and gives her suggestion and of
course this is based on Jane's views and
her history and the data that she's
collected over her years in high school
next time approaches Bella they'll ask
him hey do you like the field of science
and Sam goes yes and then Bella goes do
you like new in industry he like new
things coming up in industry and Sam
goes yes and Bella goes you know you
should similar to Jane Villa also forms
a decision tree based on Sam's response
and gives her suggestion and it says hey
how about artificial intelligence Sam's
like Oh artificial intelligence
so Sam next asked Terry for his
suggestion and Sam goes
scoring things and he goes yes and he
goes do you like theoretical and he goes
no and he comes up and says mathematics
so you have two people saying
mathematics at once or persons
suggesting artificial intelligence since
two out of three friends suggested math
Sam decides to take mathematics and
there's a lot of subtleties in this
example it's actually a really good
example some of the things we run into
in data science is when we collect data
and we collect from different sources we
might have data from one source that
measures one thing or one set of
instruments and we might have data from
another source that majors something
else we saw that with each of his
friends are measuring different things
and asking different questions that's a
little bit bit beyond the scope of this
particular tutorial so let's go back to
our wine cellar so you see more the
number of decision trees more accurate
will be the prediction random forests
have a number of applications in market
already if you've been watching any of
our other tutorials you'll see that
these are very common we have in banking
it can be used to predict fraudulent
customers is used to analyze symptoms of
patients and detecting the disease in
e-commerce the recommendations are
predicted based on customers activity
stock market trends can be analyzed to
predict profit or loss most recently I
was watching a review on weather here in
the United States and the data they pull
in for that and one of the tough weather
places actually uses five different
models random forest was one of them I
believe they use five different models
to predict the weather and depending on
what the models come up with and what's
going on some of the models do better
than others I thought that was really
interesting it's important to note so
when you see us repeat the same things
over and over and you're looking at the
different machine learning tools you
realize it we use multiple tools to
solve the same problem and we can find
the best one that fits for that
particular situation so let's see how
that fits back in our wine production to
help speed up the process of wine
production we will automate the
prediction of wine quality suppose our
random forest bills three decision trees
we have the first decision tree which is
going to defy
everything by chlorides less than 0.08
and it's either yes or no and then it's
gonna look at alcohol greater than six
yes or no quality equals high quality
not so good and if the chlorides were
greater than 0.08 quality equals low so
there's our first treat and then our
second tree is going to split it on
sulfates less than 0.6 and pH pH less
than 3.5 again we have it coming down
here that if the pH is low and the
sulfites are low the quality equals high
if the pH is a little higher but the
sulfides are low it's not so good and if
the sulfides are greater than 0.6 we
have a quality equal below and then
we'll do a third decision tree we'll
split it based on pH and we can see
below how that tree looks like with our
sugar less than 2.5 if not it's a
quality equals low since we're low
quality and if it is less than 2.5 then
the pH decide whether it's gonna be a
quality 5 or not so good and if we track
one of our wines down the list we'll
look at it we'll say Oh two out of three
decision trees indicate the quality of
our wine to be 5 the whole force
predicts the same so this sounds
promising so let's go ahead and dive in
and see what that actually looks like so
this is the data set that holds all the
attribute values required to predict the
wines quality and I'll pull this up in a
spreadsheet in just a moment but you can
see here we have fixed acidity volatile
acidity citric acid all the way to
quality and then quality is like a 4 or
5 6 or 7 I believe and this will be done
in R so let's go ahead and get started
in our coding we'll be using our studio
before we dive into our studio I always
like to open up the data and the
spreadsheet and look at the actual data
that I have and they've called it wine
quality - red dot XLS so it's a
spreadsheet up a Microsoft spreadsheet
and when we open it up we'll see that it
matches what we had before as far as the
slide was showing us with the we have 12
different columns the first 11 are our
features are fixed acidity volatile acid
citric acid things you always want to
look at when you're looking at your data
and we've done this before in the part 1
but just a reminder we want to note that
we have decimal places here float values
in a lot of these things especially the
first number of columns our freeze
sulfur dioxide looks to be an integer
but it's varies a lot so we have you
know I see some values all the way up to
51 7 4 so we'd probably keep this as
it's a linear model kind of thing same
thing with the sulfur dioxides densities
again decimal places sulfides alcohol
quality I want you to note in the
quality that we only have a few
qualities here this isn't like a spread
between 0 and 100 it looks to be 3 4 5 6
& 7 and so when we start looking at the
process we can have the option of either
doing this as a series of integers or
float values going from 3 to 7 or we can
convert that to a categorical 3 4 5 6
and 7 being the categories but we'll
look at that in the coding here in just
a minute and finally you'd want to go
ahead and scroll down through the data
and just look for missing data or
anything weird obviously working with
big data you wouldn't be able to do that
if this was spread across numerous
computers and you had millions of caught
rows we have what 16 hundred and
eighty-seven rows here so it's a nice
sized spreadsheet still considered a
small data set let's go ahead and switch
over let's take a look at this in the R
so here we are in our our studio and if
you remember it's comes up automatically
in three panels I have my font on fairly
large to help out the upper left panel
is a file that's opening there multiple
files and tabs open as you can see on
mine right now I'll probably close most
of those in just a minute and this is
where you can put in your commands then
you can execute these commands by either
clicking on the run box or ctrl enter is
the hotkeys for that and all that does
is inputs that down in the console and
execute that line of command you could
just paste these directly in the console
I've certainly been known to do that if
I'm loading up some data and I just want
to take a quick look at it in R because
I'm doing the coding and something else
or if I just want to do a quick explore
before I dive in and figure out what
needs to be done that's one of the
tricks you can do and then on the right
hand side we have our environment and
history connections we mainly are gonna
just be sitting on plots and I'm just
gonna minimize this for right now out of
the way when we dive in if you haven't
yet you do need to go ahead and install
the package random forests I'm not
actually going to do that because I've
already run that we don't need to rerun
that but I am gonna go ahead and import
it into our project with the library and
then random forests and we'll do the
ctrl enter you can always hit the Run
button up there too and then now the
library has been uploaded in there you
can see down below it takes this and
just copies it and paste it down below
and runs it in our console and then just
a quick troubleshooting thing my java
happens to be the developers job the
latest release of the developers java
from last week is clashing with my AR
and rerouting my java files so you
chances are you don't need to look this
up or find out where your Java is but
there's a JRE folder if you do have an
error that comes up next in the next
library you look that up it's usually
under Program Files Java and you'll see
JDK depending on what version you have
on there and then find that JRE folder
and I'm just gonna set the environment
on there you have to do that every time
you run the script so with our there is
a place in our where you can set it
permanently but generally it's set to
whatever your system variables are set
to so you don't want to mess with that
so you just want to put this in your
code if you're having problems and you
can always take it out then we need to
go ahead and bring in another library
and we're going to be importing a
spreadsheet so it's an X the xlsx and
since a Microsoft spreadsheet I'll go
ahead and run that
let's go ahead and create a variable
path we're gonna assign to a variable
path the location of our folder so this
is a very lengthy one you'll have to
copy and paste it off your computer my
name is Richard and sooner it's under
seat column users richer's documents
talks business simply learn marketing
random forest and then the actual file
which is wine quality - red dot XLS so I
put in the whole path in here you could
also set the computer path to whatever
folder you have it in and then just use
just the name of the file but I went
ahead and did this because it a lot of
times it's good to be aware where your
paths are going where you're pulling
your data from and again it with the
ctrl enter so I could you'll see that
that pushed the line down below and ran
that line so our path is now set
and then let's create a variable called
data
and we'll assign that to a read and
we're gonna be reading see where is it
there it is and spreadsheet and before I
put in we need the path but we also need
one more thing on the spreadsheet
because it is an Excel spreadsheet we
need to know which page were on so let's
go look that up and in the spreadsheet
this might be a little hard to see cuz
it's a very tiny font down there but
you'll see the page tabs on the bottom
this actually has two different pages
and we want page 1 for this project so
let's flip back over and put that in our
code and the term they use this sheet
index I always have to look that stuff
up and it was sheet index of 1 we'll go
ahead and execute this so at this point
we've now loaded the data into the
variable data and it's reading those and
I think there was like a couple thousand
rows a date in there so it takes it just
a moment to pull it in
once I have my data in there I always
like to do something like this data and
in always forgetting are its head data
and we can run that and you'll see it
prints out that what we looked at in the
spreadsheet so we have our fixed acidity
volatile acidity citric acid residual
sugar chlorides free sulfur all the
different things we're actually looking
for quality so you want to keep that in
mind that quality is the final setting
is it three four five six what is the
quality on there and the first thing we
need to do is we're actually going to
take the data quality and let me see
quality there it is in our the dollar
sign means that you're looking at one of
the columns in here or features as it is
so we see data dollar sign quality and
our that means that's what we're going
to be editing and what we want to do is
we want to change the quality just a
little bit so we're going to set it
equal to
we're not assigning a variable we're
altering it so data dollars and quality
equals and we want to do as is one of
the functions in our we're gonna do as a
factor
and then data quality because that's
what we're actually editing on there and
this stop just for a second and look at
this factor takes this and looks at the
data as a categorically so instead of it
being on a continual scale of you know
zero to a hundred or something like that
it actually looks at it as category of
five category of six category of a kind
of quarry of cat category of dog there
yes or no categories versus a continual
now there's a lot of different things in
here that we can do the same thing with
but all of these really are linear
numbers seven point four point seven Oh
sulfur dioxide 3467 so we really know we
need to mess with into the other
variables in there but we do want to go
ahead and set this up and we'll come up
here when do our control enter and
you'll run it down below and you'll see
data quality equals as factor data
quality so we've now turned that into a
factor or into a categorical data and so
let me just bring this down a little bit
the guys in the back to the rest of this
next piece of code there are so many
different ways and if you have been
looking at any of our tutorials this
should look kind of familiar this is one
way to do it
you'll see we have our training data and
our testing data and so we've done here
is we've got it we have a data set size
equals
and we're just gonna do by the row and
so we want point eight or eighty percent
of the data is going to be our training
set to train our for us and if you train
it forest or any machine learning model
of course want to test it so we're gonna
save twenty percent of the data for
testing and when you look at this we
have the index which we set at 80
percent comma and then a negative index
so that's the remaining setup so it goes
from that index on these is our notation
for sorting out that data and then we
create the index and we use a term
sample and this is just going to go in
there and set our different samples for
in row size data set size and everything
so we have an index now so the data is
indexed and we're just going to pull off
the first set of index on the end of the
index for our data and we can run all of
this in one shot well go into code and
we'll run select in lines and so now we
have our data in here we have our
training set and our testing set that's
what we wanted to get to so once we
format it all the data then we get to if
it's the next real easy step which is a
single line to bring in our random
forest so let's go ahead and please a
variable our F descending for random
forests and we're gonna assign if you
remember correctly we brought in our
library random if you wonder why I go up
here all the time is because I'll forget
which letters are capitalized in some of
these because I switch between packages
so much but it's random with a capital F
for forest random forests so the our F
is going to equal random forests and of
course the we start by telling it which
column we're trying to predict and of
course you can always go down here and
double check we're running this on the
quality there we go quality and we're
using just that column all the way to
the end
and then we've added our team in the
back has gone in and played with this a
little bit and we'll go a little bit
over what they did but I'm gonna put in
the values that they have set for the
different options in the random forest
before I do that it would help if I tell
it what data to use data is going to
equal our training set and then we have
the variables that they put together and
let's just talk a little bit about what
these different variables mean
so I am try and entry these are some of
the variables you play with with the
random for us
I am trying not so much when they first
put it out I think M try was very common
for is a good value I can't remember
what the default is but it's probably
three four or five or something like
that depending I think it depends on how
many features you have going in there so
you could even just leave this as a
default without too much troubles the
entry this is where it gets important
and I'm going to make this 200 one one
of the suggestions is to always make
this odd like a tiebreaker just in case
the default is like 500 or 501 and then
finally we have importance equals true I
can't remember what it defaults to but
generally you want to set the importance
equals to true it actually looks at the
correlation between the different
features to make sure that there is some
kind of correlation as it's doing its
calculations so our one line of code is
going to assign our random forest and go
ahead and train around and for us all in
one execution so this whole thing has
been centered around getting to our F
set to the random forest and let's go
ahead and execute this variable or this
line of code and you'll see it takes a
little bit down here to execute as it
goes through and sets it up
and you'll see it probably takes a
minute or so to execute the code
depending on the size of the data and
how good your machine is and then with
all of our data we can start looking at
the answers and we'll just do our F will
execute that and you'll see that the
random forest does a nice job you can
see right here has our data equals
training it basically goes everything we
talked about and you come down here and
it has a confusion matrix which is nice
we always like our confusion matrix when
we're talking to our shareholders and
explaining what the data comes out with
and how it trains and we can go ahead
and plot our RF let's see what that
looks like and as a number of force
grows you remember we set it to two
thousand and one forest you can also see
how the error comes in how the different
error are the different variables this
kind of a nice graph that gives you an
idea it might help you adjust whether
you really want to do two thousand
different for us you might actually
truncate this off and around maybe eight
hundred because you notice the lines
kind of continue on again this is just
still on the plot and of course the next
step is we need to go ahead and predict
remember we split our data into two
groups so let's go ahead and get a
result we'll call it result and we'll
assign this one there we go well set
this to a data frame there we go there's
our data frame and then let's call this
we have our test our test quality that's
what we're we're setting up on our test
group with the quality on there
then we want to have a predict nice
little keyword there to go ahead and run
our random for us and then we tell it
that we're gonna predict using our RF
our random forest our testing Group 1 to
11 is what we're using type equals
response so let's go ahead and execute
it that's a mouthful on there somewhere
I left out a comma in there so it gave
me an error but you can see right here
we've set in there now we have a result
and just real quick we could do the head
or the result result comma 5 and just
take a look at the first five lines and
you'll see we have the actual value and
what we predicted over here and we could
also just do all of the results and just
see what that looks like whoops and
print that out
and so it has all the different data
we're going through on there
and finally let's just go ahead and plot
there we go we'll put plot up here plot
let's plot the result and just see what
that looks like maybe not the best one
to show to the shareholders but does
give me an idea on the left on the
y-axis you'll see that it predicted
eight and this tells you that it a lot
of the eight and the eight scale was
pretty probably gave us about fifty
percent came up there at eight really
maybe fifty percent it didn't guess
right but it did come up there and say
that it was at least a four or five or
six even where it was considered an
eight and so on you can see these
different blocks coming in so that if
you line up the three with the three
four with the four and you kind of cross
index some heat map would probably do
better but for this example we'll just
do a quick plot of the data as far as
how it works and you can again see the
results that we predicted over here and
you can lick those over of course back
in the wine cellar we're talking to our
vineyard owner and if you remember from
before we looked at this chart right
here the error rate is twenty nine point
zero five percent therefore our accuracy
is seventy point nine five percent if
you're doing a vineyard there's probably
pretty good accuracy and always check
your domain when you're sharing this
stuff because if you're doing something
that's life or death maybe 70% accuracy
might not be so good but if you're
looking at where you're gonna distribute
the bottles to for the wine and who's
gonna drink it you know seventy percent
accuracy is pretty good for that that's
probably a lot better than having no
accuracy whatsoever and not even knowing
what wines going out to who so we have
automated the process of predicting the
quality of wine I myself prefer to
predict it by sampling it that's great
thank you I'd like to visit this guy and
sample his wine and find out just how
good his different vineyards are so the
key takeaways today what is a random
forest so we discussed the random forest
that can be used for both classification
and regression we discussed how the
random forest works where we have the
three different trees where he's asking
his help with this school and then based
on the answers of those three and who
came up in agreement when
so mathematics is what they came up with
and then we had some applications of
random forest which covers pretty much
any of our data science it's out there
right now and then we talked about
training the random forest you saw how
easy it was we created our RF a variable
and we signed it the random forest and
trained it all in one line of script so
it was very quick and easy we discussed
a little bit with the EM try and a
little bit of the entry to know how many
trees to use for this and finally we did
the predicting quality of wine using R
so we had a final prediction on there
there was about 70% accurate again thank
you for joining us today for more
information visit www.subscriptorium.com